we are in quite a bit of debt um almost
$200,000 in Consumer
Debt and I have three car loans that we
are upside down all three how How far
underwater what do these loans add up to
on these cars yes okay so the uh the
smallest one is 15,000 okay then the
next one is 20
27,000 and then the biggest one is
49,000 so in your bu how much margin is
left after making all your minimum
payments all $2,000 of car loans plus
all the other debt is there anything
left yeah so as we just did the every do
we just did the budget and for like this
month we had a couple extra things to do
this month like getting tires for one of
the cars but besides that our normal
what we have left to throw a debt is
between around eight to uh $800 to
$1,000 a month